joining us now from labour this morning
is the shadow mental health minister dr
rosanna allen khan frontline doctor of
course um we're hearing from the
government this morning good morning to
you saying that what we saw last night
uh that mob that surrounded not only the
leader but also the shadow foreign
secretary nothing to do with jimmy
salmon
it's so disturbing nobody wants to see
scenes like that play out for any
politician of any political party but i
think
when we listen to some of the language
that was being said it's very clear that
that words have consequences and some of
the words that the prime minister used
when he was trying to smear secure
stamina
were used yesterday but quite frankly if
if the prime minister is truly sorry
about what happened he would come to
parliament and apologize unreservedly
for his comments last week because we
have seen that when you occupy the
highest office in the land what you say
matters
and when he called muslim women
letterboxes we know that hate crimes
around the country towards muslim women
went up and
he has such a prominent platform and
what he says matters and he should not
be delving into the dark corners of the
deep web to find smears and conspiracy
theories to take down anyone that
disagrees with him
um
we've got to grab um of the prime
minister in blackpool he did clarify
what he'd said and just to to clarify
this is what the prime minister said in
blackpool last week
talking not about uh the leader of the
opposition's personal
um record when he was uh when he was dpp
and i and i totally understand that he
had nothing to do
personally with those decisions
clarified it
he hasn't apologized has he he needs to
provide more than a clarification he
needs to unreservedly come to the house
and apologize like so many of his mps
are asking him to do that the british
public at this time when they are facing
a cost of living crisis wondering how
they're going to choose between heating
and eating the last thing they need now
is a prime minister who's so busy trying
to cover his own back and deflect from
his own shortcomings and rule breaking
during lockdown yeah quite frankly this
in particular though
and you know he doesn't feel he needs to
apologize because what he's done is
clarified what he meant so there's no
apology necessary
i think he needs to come and apologize
unreservedly and then why what before
because he said that's what he meant
no he needs to apologize because what he
did was quite frankly smear secure
stammer and it has had consequences but
also what he's trying to do is deflect
from the fact that he is not
fit for the job he is not dealing with
what matters to the country today okay
there are people who are having to
choose between heating and eating i'm
seeing patients in my emergency
department where i work in st george's
coming in with burns toddlers coming in
the skulls all over their bodies because
they're using old water bottles and
their parents cannot afford to pay the
bills these are the real issues facing
the country
and this deflection of trying to smear
secure stamina and the fact that we're
now all talking about that rather than
the fact that today in parliament we
have an opposition day debate looking at
the importance of children's mental
health and talking about some real
tangible things we can do to improve
children's mental health we're instead
talking yet again about this smear and
quite frankly
needs to get a grip he didn't want to
smear kia's drama he clarified the
situation that was not his intention
well i don't believe that for a hot
second he made a choice last week when
he came to parliament he could have
apologized for what he had done he let's
be very clear we have the minister if he
has anything to apologize this within
this highlights the problem that is him
um we come into public office to serve
our communities and boris johnson has
come into public office to serve himself
and with an 80-seat majority and he will
happily smear anyone who stands in his
way look kay we all know that those
closest to him last week even jumped
ship he's there singing i will survive
while we have a country who is
struggling to survive they are
struggling to put food on the table for
their families but he is a survivor he's
still there and he's got an 80-seat
majority and um it's a little bit like
an echo chamber isn't it because you can
shout across as much as you want in the
chamber they're still sitting pretty
with the uh percentage that they have i
don't think they're sitting that pretty
at the end of the day he's losing trust
of his own staff those closest to him
he's losing trust of his mps and i
believe he's lost the trust of the
country and but quite frankly okay what
we need to be doing is just getting on
with the job and talking about what
really matters as the labour party
should you guys not just leave this and
you know forget about alleged smears or
whatever and just say okay well we have
left thicker skin than this and we're
just going to we have left it we have
two opposition day debates today first
of all talking about the cost of living
and food security the second one talking
about children's mental health last week
we were talking about the energy price
cap and the fact that people cannot
afford their bills and the cost of
living crisis is is flawing families
it's us that's getting on with the job
and the conservatives who are quite
frankly infighting and and letting the
country down how are our kids getting on
when it comes to mental health it's been
such a challenging two years for them i
know okay they are really really
struggling and that's why what we're
putting forward today is a package where
we have said that when we're in
government at the end of our first
parliament we will recruit eight and a
half thousand mental health staff we
will guarantee that every person begins
treatment within a month not just gets
put on a waiting list but begins
treatment we we are calling for a
counsellor in every secondary school and
a shared counsellor to cover every
single primary school and we're also
calling for there to be open access
mental health hubs in the community i
know this is something that you care
about a lot as well it is but how are
you going to pay for it well what we
will do is we will
levy v80 on private school fees um which
will raise
440 million pounds we will also close
the carried interest tax
loophole which will raise 1.7 billion
pounds and we will use 576 million of
that uh for children's mental health
okay is that enough
well this is ambitious um we believe
that this is what will enable us to um
provide all the things that i have just
spoken about but quite frankly we have
children i mean i see children coming
into my um a e who have had to wait
sometimes over 700 days around our
country over 700 days for mental health
support and we know that not investing
in just one child's mental health has an
impact for the whole family if you have
to give up work because your child is
self-harming or you're worried that they
are worried about taking their own lives
that has an impact on you and your job
and your mental health and the siblings
in the family so it is a false economy
not to invest in our children's mental
health it's pmq's tomorrow what would
you say to both of the leaders ahead of
pmqs
put the country first
i think the government need to stop the
smearing and get on with the job and i
have every faith in in you know secure
stamina he delivers at every single
pmq's and i'm looking forward to what
he's going to have to say tomorrow